dans le documentaire les journalistes
ont suivi notamment dylan ex koh lanta
qui est devenu influenceurs et le jeune
homme s'installe à dubaï pour y vivre sa
vie et poursuivre son business et c'est
vrai que ma mère m'a appelé hier elle
m'a dit mais sont très riches ces gens
chez moi un appartement confortable
qu'il a lui-même personnalisé avec entre
autres des portraits de lui
je suis quelqu'un qui fait attention à
moi c'est important sur ce compte et
influenceurs de prendre soin de soi et
si notre bon exemple c'est tu préfères
te montrer compter ferait bien à bien
que dégueulasse
j'ai voulu venir dans un endroit ça
bougeait beaucoup plus et le fife palme
c'est réputé pour que ça bouge tous les
jours grâce au placement de produit et à
ses différentes activités
le jeune homme gagne plus de 50000 euros
par mois oui c'est ça la vie mais bon on
a bossé pour on a bossé pour ses pas
tombée du ciel dans les thoniers
elle avait reçu exécuté mais je veux
d'ailleurs il avait des mocassins le
gland c'était moi d'avoir et ça alors il
ya plein de gens qui ont réagi là dessus
moi j'ai plein de potes qui m'ont envoyé
mes dix mois cinquante mille euros pour
vendre des paquets de chips nan mais
sans déconner gilles verdez oui encore
enfin il est très sincère mais il
déclare 50000 euros en fait et gagné un
peu plus il y en a qui viennent jusqu'à
300 400 mille euros c'est fou et le
problème c'est que pour les jeunes ça
devient presque d'ailleurs dans le
reportage on dit presque une obsession
battre influenceurs c'est le métier de
rêve matériel métier de rêve il faut pas
que tout le monde pense que les jeunes
vont tous devenir influenceurs oui des
faits ou l'irak tiré dessus mais en fait
effectivement il ya des personnes qui
ont été choqués parce qu'il ya des
grosses sommes d'argent
en même temps quand on regarde ces
documentaires on sait que les
influenceurs s'est montrée ces flambées
c'est des maisons de mode c'est tout
donc pourquoi être choqués effectivement
aujourd'hui influenceurs on gagne
beaucoup d'argent c'est comme ça philips
a présenté regardez moi ça c'est aussi
un autre planète pour moi la page je
sais pas pour voilà je si ça tombe du
ciel
alors quand j'entends le mec dit c'est
pas tombée du ciel bastien et mais
attention parce que la pluie s'arrête de
nous entend et j'ai l'impression que
c'est tout ça n'est pas n'est pas un
métier tout ça n'est pas sérieux
j'arrive pas à prendre ça au sérieux et
ça me fait peur c'est s'arrêter un jour
ça ce que moi je pense que oui parce que
c'est une butte oui parce que mon enfant
moi je suis étonné du nombre
d'influenceurs kidian extrêmement bien
longtemps qu'il gagne 4,5 millions et en
aquitaine comme l'a déjà pour faire ce
qui a quatre simples rodez de ces normes
et surtout j'ai l'âme est normal de
chaud vous dit qu'il parte qui gagne
2,58 à 300 millions moi je suis content
pour eux franchement oui non mais c'est
pas le débat tiens toujours très
admirative des gens qui travaillent
voilà quelle que soit quel que soit le
salaire travail et c'est très important
dans sa vie de bosser et j'ai moi je
j'adore les gens qu'il ya une plaque
d'argent je profiterai pas du système
saison médiocre débat voilà mais c'est
mais voilà oui bernard qu'il faut
maintenant le vrai problème il est pas
là ils ont raison ainsi en raison ils
ont mais tant mieux pour eux moi je me
sens très bien
c'est des beaux gosses et des belles
filles font des photos c'est un boulot
de faire ça ok en revanche si l'évasion
fiscale oui alors et après quand ils
veulent se faire soigner il rentre en
france alors écrite et que même la
france ça c'est un peu plus difficile
je suis environ chine-ue tibaoui
franchement pourquoi pas les
influenceurs à paris jeudi
moment des solidaires avec son pays non
cela dit votre jeu les palmiers ça je
comprend trois jours les pins on a des
paluds enfants il faut dire qu'elle me
faut rappeler aux téléspectateurs qui
n'y a pas aucun impôt de tout ce qui vit
là-bas il ya aucun impôt ni sioniste
rien donc évidemment manque de pot quand
ils ont besoin de se faire soigner il
rentre en france et après ça c'est pas
bien à l'arjel
on paie des impôts poignet mais tapons
aussi sur les sportifs les artistes à
élargir à l'étranger en suisse ou
ailleurs mais la baraque aux excuses et
moi je suis entièrement d'accord mais
y'a pas que tout le monde est unanime à
l'entente pas dessus je dis simplement
qu'il faut le faire remarquer gibier ont
voulu rajouter quelque chose non mais ce
qui me fascine c'est le modèle
économique c'est que commet comme vous
l'avez dit quand vous vendez des chips
ou de bonbons vous générez 300000 euros
par mois c'est qu'ils ont une vraie
force de vente les influences vraiment
les gens quand dylan dit à ses abonnés à
ses followers htc bonbons c'est à dire
qu'il y en a cinquante milles qui les
achète réellement c'est ça qui est
incroyable ils ont une vraie force de
bucquoy pas regarder que c'est quand il
est à 10 quand il dit j'ai fait le
régime comme j'aime c'est avec benjamin
c'est vous qui marchez mieux je crois
oui hein c'est ça quand vous parler les
gens vous est coupable bien sûr nous
allons obligé de tendre l'oreille
moi j'ai trouvé le nomme de guillaume
très très instructif parce que
honnêtement les 50000 euros mais moi
alors moi ce hammam est anesthésié
désespérée des prix mais je me dis
qu'effectivement je suis est ce qu'un
salaire comme ça rtl de 50000 euros pour
ces d'un animateur ou pas dans tout le
jeu
l'argent le mana l'argent représente pas
grand chose dans mon esprit ce que ce
calcul très très mal mais je pense qu'un
mec qui touche sa oui d'accord oui mais
je mets à ibos demain ya les chiffres
radio qui tombe d'ailleurs et je vous
lis petites infos de ce que c'est france
inter sera première à d'autres en scène
avec un écart encore plus important
c'est à dire mais elle est dans les
choux dit c'est pas la peine de rêver un
écart encore plus important at-elle et
je vous dis ça me désole
ça nous désole aussi un moment je vais
tout un coup dans la fourmilière